because they're lying to us not care
about a perceived deal we want better
equipment protective gear
we have no mass in the middle of this
coronavirus crisis I am obviously one of
the lucky ones I can just get my work
done at home on a laptop with my tiny
co-worker Liam here who's four months
old but obviously there are many many
people in this country who aren't in
that position who still have to go to
jobs grocery stores warehouses factories
etc it's a little hard to tell exactly
how many people are still going to those
kinds of jobs but the Brookings
Institution estimates that before the
kovat crisis there were as many as 62
million people in those jobs and no
doubt many of them are still going to
work and what started to happen in
recent days is since those jobs have
become a lot more risky some of those
workers are starting to strike for
better working conditions in the past
couple weeks we've seen walk outs at
Perdue at McDonald's and instacart at
Whole Foods at Amazon there is this
national and global crisis which is
being experienced in a particularly
acute way in a number of workplaces that
many people in America have not thought
of as places where workers have much
leverage and some of the calculation
that workers make about whether it's
worse confronting the boss whether it's
worth acting collectively that
calculation is shifted when people have
real fears about it being dangerous to
come into work if they don't have
changes made
[Music]
workers at an Amazon warehouse facility
on Staten Island are staging a walkout
today they're complaining about the fact
that their facility has not been cleaned
out since a worker there tested positive
they think up to six other workers may
have tested positive as well and they
want Amazon to close down that
distribution center for a period of time
have it entirely sanitized tell me a
little more about the Amazon situation
you know we've heard a lot about this
Staten Island warehouse but I guess
there's a couple other locations as well
they've now been walkouts at Amazon
warehouses in Staten Island in Chicago
and in Michigan in each of these cases
you have workers saying that company is
not doing enough to keep them safe I'm
doing this because of my health and my
fellow workers else as well it should be
closed though it should be treated
properly sort of that the complaint they
had was round with the workers that was
a lack of transparency around it's just
how they were being told about positive
Kovac cases than their workforce they
say you know sometimes it took too long
and so they walked out over it and then
breast management which done some
demands about sick pay should they get
the virus and that kind of thing what
are you gonna say that you need that
protection as well we need to know that
we want to feel safe while working and
that's it Amazon released a statement on
the day of the walkout saying that the
protesters accusations were unfounded
and saying we have taken extreme
measures to keep people safe tripling
down on deep cleaning procuring safety
supplies that are available and changing
processes to ensure that those in our
buildings are keeping safe distances
amazon also offers an example of one of
the challenges for this worker pushback
a leader of the strike in Staten Island
the same day that the strike happened
was terminated by Amazon we had a
successful walkout you know we got the
message out we got people aware that's
what we here for Amazon says they
weren't retaliating for raising safety
concerns they were actually enforcing
safety rules
but that strike leader says he was being
punished for standing up for his
coworkers the question of what happens
to workers who stand up and whether
those protests become inspirations or
cautionary tales about how you can get
yourself in an even worse situation is
crucial and people are going to take
mixed messages from some of these
examples let's talk about the situation
with Whole Foods tell me about what's
been going on there yeah so to add to
the strike parade I guess that Amazon
which all until foods they air workers
are a subset of them started holding a
sick-out on Tuesday where folks called
in sick they were asking for better
protections on sales floors you know
some folks had wanted masks in recent
weeks and excited some fuzzy guidance
from management on that and just again
the general feeling that you know
something were to happen to them they
want guarantee it's from management that
they'd have their cost covered or gonna
be able to care for family members
myself and all the you know Whole Foods
employees need to keep putting as much
pressure on them as possible to make
these changes you know from the
employees the customers in public health
and and the good of the company frankly
paid sick leave reimbursement for
testing you know hazard pay and a firm
policy for shutting down stores when
employees as positive recovered 19 you
know you know all these things have big
implications for for safety you know not
just for the employees but but for the
customers and the public health at large
have you heard about any changes that
the company is going to make in response
to this action
we don't know exactly how many people
called out sick but we talked to workers
in Illinois New York New Jersey
Pennsylvania Texas because if they did
that on Tuesday company says its
operations weren't affected stores
remained open
so those Whole Foods and Amazon strikes
are really just the tip of the iceberg
in the past week and a half or so we've
seen demonstrations by employees at a
Purdue chicken plant in Georgia
sanitation workers in Pittsburgh and GE
factory workers in Massachusetts all
basically advocating for similar things
safer more sanitary work conditions
although in the case of GE those workers
are also trying to get their company to
switch over to more manufacturing of
ventilators for hospitals workers at
McDonald's are also getting in on the
action in several states led by the
advocacy organization fight for 15 we
was told we're not to wear masks are
gloves about a GM here at McDonald she
was told by McDonald's we're not
supposed to use masks and the reason
we're out here today is because we
wonder what they're gonna do about our
safety right now they're doing nothing
so is any of this having an effect well
in some cases it seems like the answer
is a cautious yes just in the past
couple days we've seen McDonald's
announced that they're going to
introduce better safety practices and
that they're even considering hazard pay
for some workers and Amazon has
announced that starting early next week
it's going to be handing out masks to
all its employees and doing temperature
checks at all of its warehouse locations
so it seems like some of these workers
at least are starting to get some of
what they want the question now for many
labor organizers is can these short-term
concessions be parlayed into more
permanent change for American labor
what's going on now creates an opening
for various kinds of organizing that
might not have been there before we will
know more in the weeks and months ahead
about how much these protests change
things and to what extent they lead to
changes that outlast the coronavirus and
to what extent they can lead to
organization and leverage for workers
that outlast this current very unusual
moment
[Music]
you
you